[Music]
yes amazon's the rings of power takes
place thousands of years before the
hobbit in the lord of the rings but to
immortal beings once a few millennia
the rings of power actor robert aramaio
said of his character elrond when i read
about him i'm always really interested
in the way that tolkien talks about how
elrond is counted amongst the immortals
which is an interesting thing counted it
doesn't necessarily say that he is one
biologically speaking elrond is
definitely immortal but he's also
related to mortal men immortal elves and
even the angelic mayar elron's critical
role is the bridge between many of
middle earth's peoples combined with his
eternal nature keeps him in the
spotlight for a very long time i was
there the day the strength of men failed
in the rings of power he's a scrappy
young politician by the time we see him
in the hobbit films he's the leader of
rivendale and a member of the white
council he continues in that capacity in
the lord of the rings helping point
characters including frodo and aragorn
in the right direction by the end of
that story he does leave middle-earth
for a quiet retirement in the blessed
realm in the west by that point he's
more than earned it
over the years tolkien struggled with
galadriel's role in middle earth he
wrote his way through it it seems the
book unfinished tales has an entire
section titled the history of galadriel
and kelliborn while full of interesting
facts and parts of stories the text
contradicts itself and presents multiple
versions of the heroine's role one thing
that's clear is that tolkien wanted
galadriel to play an essential role in
the second age and the rings of power
showrunners have used that as an
opportunity to make her essentially the
serious lead at least so far galadriel
was also a founding member of the white
council during the third age this
allowed peter jackson to insert her into
the hobbit films when that group takes
down the necromancer in mirkwood and the
lady of lorien plays an essential role
in the lord of the rings hosting and
helping the fellowship on their way to
mordor i will diminish
and go into the west
and remain galadriel in peter jackson's
adaptation of the lord of the rings the
dark lord sauron's eye sits perched atop
his massive tower of bharadur in the
land of shadows scanning the countryside
for any sign of trouble sauron also
appears in the hobbit trilogy of films
this time in the form of the necromancer
originally a minor character jackson
took sauron's foreboding presence and
inserted it as a major plot point in his
own version of that story
tauron's presence is likewise felt from
the beginning of the rings of power he's
briefly in the prologue for the first
episode then his sigil starts showing up
everywhere and he's even named multiple
times when he does finally reveal
himself it will likely be in his more
attractive form as anatar the lord of
gifts there's one more character in the
movies and the show gilgalad has a brief
cameo at the beginning of the fellowship
of the ring and is already in prime
videos series besides that small role
and three big ones no one else from
peter jackson's films is confirmed for
the rings of power as of now but a few
other names could join the list as the
story plays out first off there's
gandalf fans have been debating who the
man in the fire could be since he first
appeared in the marketing while the
mystery hasn't been solved in the early
episodes it's clear that the show could
be working gandalf into the story
legolas is another since the adventuring
elp's backstory is relatively vague
there's a chance that we could see the
character pop up in the rings of power
jackson found a way to fit him into the
hobbit after all some other
possibilities include thranduil who was
the king of merc wood long before he
appeared in the hobbit it was also tree
beard we know that the new series will
have ants and according to the lore
treebeard was their leader at that time
to say anything in all
english
[Music]